bueno acaban ya de de anunciarse que las
alarmas han cesado los ataques han
parado pero lo que nos encontramos
durante la noche fueron ataques con
misiles según se han informado la
oficina de del presidente lo que oíamos
en kiev fueron la esta defensa antiaérea
que sonaba constantemente lo que han
dicho quienes siguen monitorean la
guerra es que es tal vez el ataque con
misiles más grande que se ha dado en
kiev desde el comienzo de esta invasión
a gran escala y lo que estaban haciendo
estos misiles es Buscando la ubicación
de esos misiles Patriotas se veía en el
cielo retumbar y amarillo en explosiones
Pero ellos pedían a la población que por
favor no publicara fotos para no
descubrir la posición de esos de ese
sistema antiaéreo de defensa antiaéreo
aquí en la capital
no Catalina este ataque llega luego de
la gira Europea de zelensky quien dijo
haber llegado a compromisos sobre más
apoyo armamentístico que se puede
destacar aparte de esto de la visita a
varios países de Europa
que faltaba en este momento hubo varias
cayeron varias partes de misiles en
algunos lugares de kiev incluido el
zoológico Así que estaremos por tener
más información en la medida que pasa la
noche pero eso parte de lo que traía
selensky después de esta gira que hizo
por Europa era también nuevos sistemas
de defensa aéreo y sobre todo munición
para esos sistemas que es absolutamente
importante no solamente en la medida que
lanzan misiles sino también esos drones
kamikashi que no solamente buscan
destruir infraestructura sino que
también buscan
detectar Dónde están esos sistemas
también trae nuevos misiles y trae ya un
armamento más sólido según aseguran
desde presidencia de Vista a esa
contraofensiva que estamos esperando en
las próximas semanas él también estaba
buscando que le dieran aviones
especialmente ayer en Reino Unido esto
no sucedió pero sí le abrieron la puerta
para entrenar pilotos
para un futuro tener esos aviones que es
básicamente lo que está buscando Ucrania
ya desde hace bastantes semanas